bonjour je m'appelle reno et je suis adopté
du Pérou je suis le co-réalisateur du livre
la cure d'adoption un livre sur 38
histoires de personnes adoptées
international vivant ici dans le
province de quebec au canada ce livre
est très important car pour la première
peut-être que nous pouvons comprendre les gens eux-mêmes
adopté en savoir un peu plus sur le
questions que vous vous posez sur les opinions
ils ont et c'est très important pour
quiconque ici veut savoir
plus que l'adoption internationale est
Il est également important de savoir qu'il y a plus de
20 000 personnes adoptées
international vivant dans la province
de Québec alors la faute du
l'adoption pour moi est un livre que tout le monde
avoir
dans notre bibliothèque